all right it's the moment liberals the
Trump hating press have been so
anxiously waiting for former disgraced
FBI director James Comey is ready to
cash in on his very public hatred for
President Donald Trump now his book book
tour kicks off on Sunday we couldn't
have scripted this any better he's
sitting down for his first interview
with Clinton sycophant turned ABC
so-called news journalist George
Stephanopoulos watch this promo they're
running how strange is it for you to sit
here and compare the president to a mob
boss this Sunday night on ABC
things that you know but haven't said
they could damage President Trump
James Comey and to those who say you
should have brought Hillary Clinton
before a grand jury
use of interview everyone will be
talking about this president Trump
obstructing justice should donald trump
impeached Stephanopoulos combing this
Sunday night at a special time 10:00
9:00 central on ABC really mob boss
let's think about this of all the people
the former head of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation the person responsible for
taking down actual deadly criminal gangs
shouldn't James Comey know better to
make an outrageous comparison like that
now since Comey clearly doesn't know
what he's talking about we're gonna
remind the former FBI director what an
actual mob boss looks like like for
example Al Capone remember notorious
gangster organized the illicit gambling
prostitution tax evasion and of course
was responsible for an untold number of
murders including seven people in one
day which is now famously known as the
st. Valentine's Day Massacre then we got
Oh Lucky Luciano he was responsible for
widespread extortion prostitution rings
bootlegging and also murder and last but
not least we can go on all night look at
John Gotti convicted of 13 murders also
involved in racketeering tax evasion at
least illicit gambling and of course
obstruction of justice so mr. Comey
you're really going to compare the
sitting president of the United States
to a mob boss so you can make money
people that are tied to murder drugs
money laundering extortion prostitution
loan sharking and all sorts of other
rack
tearing crimes now why why you doing
this just to make yourself look good do
you really need the extra money just to
become rich and famous just to make your
point that you don't like Donald Trump
now I guess since call me if he's gonna
use the sweeping analogy I've decided
tonight
we're gonna use the Comey standard I
call it and make some comparisons of our
own now if Co me thinks Trump is a mob
boss he is in his eyes well let's talk
about a family responsible for actual
crimes we'll call it the head of the
notorious political cabal of course Bill
and Hillary Clinton the Clinton crime
family Bill Clinton as we've shown you
many times have been accused of severe
sexual misconduct harassment even rape
by juanita Broderick we know he lied
under oath and we know he paid Paula
Jones we know he was impeached I mean
while Hillary Clinton well we know she
committed crime she should have been
charged if we have equal justice under
the law she mishandled national secrets
on that ELISA private server obstructed
justice destroyed evidence and Clinton
wasn't alone in covering up her misty's
look at Cheryl Mills on the screen she
was a witness in this email
investigation declared attorney-client
privilege in order to abstain from
answering any questions attorney-client
privilege imagine that now a longtime
Clinton aide remember ooh mama Dee will
possess classified information on her
private computer uncovered in the
Anthony Weiner underage sexting
investigation and we got sketchy terry
mcauliffe
he directed his political action
committee remember donating hundreds of
thousands of dollars an obscene amount
of money to the state Senate campaign of
Jill McCabe the wife of Oh deputy FBI
director Andrew McKay and of course he
now obviously is out of that post and he
got fired and he sat on Huma Abedin Z
mails for months and of course Loretta
Lynch really we do believe that the
former attorney general had a secret
meeting on an airport tarmac with Bill
Clinton in Phoenix just days before Kobe
cleared Clinton and next of course we're
gonna look at the Clinton crime family
you have the Clinton bought and paid for
dossier that was used to get and three
times renew a FISA warrant against the
Trump campaign associate now this was
authored by ex foreign spy remember for
a national Christopher Steele working
for
using GPS hired by the law firm Perkins
Kui at the request of the Clinton
campaign and according to reports
Clinton crony Sid Vicious Blumenthal and
others shop that dossier around the
State Department and to the media now
this brings us to debbie Wasserman
Schultz okay part of the same family
okay she helped rig the primary for
Hillary Clinton as head of the DNC
according to Donna Brazile and donna of
course gave some questions before a
debate now last but not least you of
course have the Iranian one scandal and
then Secretary of State Clinton along
with the Attorney General Eric Holder
others in the Obama administration why
would we ever sign off on giving away
control of 20% of America's uranium to a
hostile actor like Russia and a Russian
state-owned company after the president
of uranium 1 pumped the Clinton
Foundation with millions of dollars of
cash will we import 90% of our uranium
now the next by the way if we're gonna
go to crime families let's look at the
Muller crime family and of course we are
now on day 329 of the Muller witch-hunt
and there's still zero evidence of
collusion imagine that and now we're
talking about stormy and Karen McDougal
oh and even the NBC Access Hollywood
tape now let's start with Mullah
remember this whole witch-hunt started
when mother's best friend James Comey
leaked his personal potentially
classified notes to his friend who was a
professor at Columbia who leaked those
notes to the press all as a purpose for
setting forward the meat wheels in
motion for a special counsel which he
got another best friend Robert Muller
we'll have more on that in a minute but
stay focused on mother during molars
time as a federal prosecutor in Boston
for four men wrongfully imprisoned for
decades framed by an FBI informant and
notorious gangster Whitey Bulger all
while Muller's office looked the other
way
and Muller was also responsible for the
prosecution of the wrong person
following the anthrax attacks after 9/11
that took place during molars tenure as
the head of the FBI and by the way in
that case with Whitey Bulger holding a
hundred million dollar payout and two of
the four people died in jail that were
put in there and they were innocent and
then look at Muller's merry band a
Democratic donors couldn't find one
Trump supporter to war
from the Special Counsel case take a
look at the side of your screen tens of
thousands of dollars to Democrats
Hillary Clinton Barack Obama not a
single penny to Donald Trump and then
you have why would anybody pick this guy
the New York Times describes his
Muller's pit bull Andrew Weissman his
aggressive prosecution tactics have
caused tens of thousands of people to
lose their jobs their livelihood in the
case against Anderson accounting now
that was eventually overturned nine zero
in the Supreme Court he's also
responsible for the imprisonment of four
Merrill Lynch executives that was
overturned by the Fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals and he has been accused twice
that I know of a withholding exculpatory
evidence by judges in cases and Weitzman
also wrote a note to Sally eighths
remember praising her for refusing to
enforce president Trump's travel ban The
Wall Street Journal reporting Weissman
attended Hillary Clinton's election
night party well you want him hired as
the pit bull to go after you in this
never-ending wide that with zero mandate
witch-hunt of robert muller cuz that's
what's happening would you want that guy
going after you with that track record
and why would Muller ever appoint that
man and then also on his team Jeanne ray
she previously is done legal work for
the Clinton Foundation huge Democratic
donor we say conflict of interest now
next up okay we have the disgraced Trump
aiding lovebirds
there's struck there's Paige who Muller
tap to help with the investigation and
based on all the text messages that so
far have been exposed as a lot more
coming hopefully one day it's apparent
that they were out to get Trump from the
very beginning and they're the ones that
texted about having the insurance policy
in case Donald Trump actually won and
called them pretty much every nasty name
in the book they got removed once their
bias was exposed now
least last but not least we have one
other crime family we want to tell you
about and well this is near and dear to
commis heart well called the Comey crime
family he loves this analogy let's stay
with it and during his tenure at the FBI
we all know about the special treatment
that Hillary Clinton received from the
bureau Comey agreed to call Clinton's
email investigation a matter when it was
an investigation at the request of
Loretta Lynch call me with Peter struck
and other
they wrote an exoneration in May before
they even interviewed her or 17 other
witnesses in July an investigation
before investigation and we also know
Comey signed off on multiple FISA
warrants against a trump campaign
associate as that rod Rosenstein Sally
Yates and others and we know that
Christopher Steele's phony dossier well
according to the Grassley gram memo that
was the bulk of the FISA application
Hillary paid for it
they never verified it according to FISA
law they should have and according the
FBI FBI protocol this is the very same
dossier that John McCain gave to Comey
after it was obtained by his associate
David Kramer and fellow Comey deep State
sycophant than CIA director John Brennan
remember he briefed Harry Reid on that
dossier Harry Reid leaked the details
about these Clinton bought and paid for
Lies to the press now knowing what we
now know about what is obvious deep
state crime families trying to take down
the president against thing with commis
analogy re now glad the Trump fired call
me this is clearly a guy that has his
own self aggrandizing arrogant agenda
who himself should be under
investigation who lied to trump
mishandled the FISA Court system maybe
even lies to the FISA Court judges will
find out leaked privileged government
documents failed to apply the law
equally which should be everybody's
concern and Comey is now set to make
millions of dollars off this impending
book tour all while trashing the
president the whole way now I again I
say to mr. Comey I'm making offer you
can't refuse come on this show you get
the whole hour I'm on 570 radio stations
with 14 million 15 million listeners
promote your book and I'll ask you tough
fair questions that the American people
deserve answered all right also tonight
we cannot forget the u.s. preparing to
respond to Syria's gas attack against
innocent men women and children the
president sending a clear warning to the
Russian President President Vladimir
Putin Trump taking to Twitter earlier
today Russia vows to shoot down any and
all missiles fired at Syria get ready
Russia because they'll be coming nice
new and smart
shouldn't be partners with a gas killing
animal who kills his own people and
enjoys it and then the president
continued our relationship with Russia
is now worse than it has ever been and
that includes during the Cold War
there's no reason for this Russia needs
us to help with their economy something
that would be very easy to do and we
need all nations to work together to
stop the arms race now much of the bad
blood with Russia is caused by the fake
and corrupt Russia investigation headed
up by all Democratic loyalists people
that work for Obama Muller is most
conflicted of all except for Rosenstein
who signed the FISA and the Comey letter
and there's no collusion so they go
crazy
so it's time for Putin to wake up and
president Trump is nothing like
President Obama you will see and we'll
keep you posted on any of these
developments at a Syria as they happen
an action could be imminent and Henry
will also join us with a full report we
have another breaking news story we are
following this is a major development
after eight months of unprecedented DOJ
obstruction under the threat of contempt
and impeachment rod Rosenstein finally
today at the last hour cooperated with
the house Intel Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez and his request to see the
original document that started this
Russia investigation now Nunez and
congressman trey gowdy and congressional
staffers they met with Rosenstein at the
DOJ today we're finally able to view a
still redacted version of the document
that was used to start this Russian
investigation
okay good step why do we have to push it
to this point and it is it amazing how
Rosenstein all of a sudden starts
cooperating after others are threatening
him with impeachment and then
threatening Christopher Rea in contempt
of Congress you know what it shouldn't
have to come to this now it's a big step
and chairman Nunez is now saying it
allows him to continue the house Intel
investigation into the DOJ and the FBI
abuses however we can't forget this is
one tiny piece of the evidence Congress
and we know Rosenstein is the one that's
obstructed he didn't want us to know
anything about FISA abuses and Congress
is subpoenaed and demanding that 1.2
million documents be turned over so
there's a long way to go
Nunez Goudy other members of Congress
they have constitutional oversight
authority